et nous sommes en ligne avec genres
divers un coordinateur du mouvement oui
au pays catalan bonjour et merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur arte france
quelles vont être les objectifs des deux
indépendantistes car les spis dumont et
tony à comment maintenant qu'ils sont
eurodéputés maintenant mettre un conseil
sur la justice espagnole puisque
m'arrive immunité qui a été décrétée par
le tribunal de l'union européenne
marie de réfugiés arrivés d'autres
autorités politiques et donc aujourd'hui
à une contradiction flagrante entre
puisqu'il décidée par la justice
suspendant d'une barre et la justice
européenne en réalité
l'espagne ne respectent pas les lois
européennes dans les factures des choses
comme un terrain de l'étape suivante
d'une part c'est montrer qu' il faut que
l'espagne respecte les décisions de
l'union européenne et ensuite provoqué
cette négociation pour pouvoir
évidemment beauté dans un référendum
d'autodétermination
vous faites référence au sort dorian
junqueras indépendantiste qui a été
condamné à 13 ans de prison est ce que
karl excuses devant et son collègue
maintenant aux députés peuvent changer
le sort de cet homme oui parce que les
décisions qui ont été prises par le par
le justice européenne dans le cas de
plus deux journées de comines
et puisqu'il sera en liberté ils ont pu
siéger doit s'appliquer aussi à un joker
puisque le la justice européenne a
décrété que tous les toits bénéficier de
l'humanité des parlementaires
républicains mois et que le marché
s'était décision l'espagnol ne respecte
pas d'aujourd'hui
un certain nombre de procédures ont été
engagées auprès des jeunes en devenir le
père pour que l'espagne sont obligés
d'accepter les décisions qui ont été
prises
je rappellerai à dire que le juge qui
les avait condamnés à détecter par les
clics ils respectent l ère édition de
l'open de l'union européenne ce qui fait
pas aujourd'hui donc la procédure va
continuer parce qu'en fait on se tourne
dans un combat pour la première fois
entre eux c'est nous c'est nouveau ça
entre les justices nationales et la
justice européenne puisque la loi
européenne nous dit que les terminaux
loupé un aujourd'hui ce sont les
dernières sont des dangers qui sur le
terrain et que les états membres doivent
respecter les décisions qui sont prises
par la justice européenne
l'espagne fait pas qu'est ce que cette
décision la cour de justice européenne
montrent que l'union européenne se range
du côté des indépendantistes comment est
ce que vous voyez les choses
pas du tout je passais tout mon père
m'emmenait de tous les cafouillages
présent jeudi au côté du droit et le
droit a été et est bien fixée par là par
la décision de régis journée dans
laquelle il était dit que la l'humanité
des élus est supérieur comme sainté les
secteurs et qu'ensuite la représentation
des électeurs est supérieur aux
décisions et des résultats et ça c'est
une nouvelle
la législation une nouvelle doctrine
juridique et que maintenant et il faut
que s'applique et dans ce sens en effet
les institutions européennes sont plutôt
du côté catalan puisque les quatre amis
et ceci depuis maintenant deux ans et
que finalement marqué que c'est un peu
long la justice européenne a donné le
quitus donné l'accord à cette émission
importante dans la construction
européenne que les citoyens sont plus
importants que l'état
et ça c'est une nouveauté est que
maintenant il faut que justice espagnole
a accepté l'appliquent merci beaucoup
aujourd'hui virage rappelle que z
coordinateur du mouvement oui au pays
catalan